[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are playing hitman because it's
elusive target week and it's elusive
targets 16 so we're gonna start doing
these videos now so if my job is to kill
this gentleman with sexy Dickie boy and
we'll try and do this by dropping a
chandelier on his head because we only
get one chance at this so we have to
make it quite iran's day so if we fail
at this we can't have another girl
that's the beauty of the elusive targets
in hitman if i die the missions all
lunch if we fail to kill him and he
escapes the missions over
so let's do this and as it's Christmas
shall we pick yes
let's pick Santa come on son - what have
you got welcome so we're going to do
this so Richard Jim McGee I know he's
already up at the cafe first of all
beeline up there to the cafe what we're
going to do we're going to knock into
him to speed up the old coins
let's grab some coins will be a sec
we're going to knock into this chest so
it speeds up everything so we don't wait
around later on like 10 minutes so while
he's getting up and getting ready we're
gonna peg it over here and we because
we're wearing our Santa Claus costume
we're just gonna climb up here and no
more bat an eyelid
well if I'm honest no one bats an eyelid
anywhere for some reason if you do this
when your suit don't worry about it
right off so once we get to the top of
here we're gonna shimmy across this
little path and jump inside the window
right or this chap inside here who's
just beyond the window to burn this
mirror here he's quite a bit of a booger
so we're going to take him out so I'll
turn the stink on and we just wait for
Bruno Mars there to hear the sink I'll
get close enough annoyingly he takes a
bit of time to walk into the room so
we're stuck here for a while while Bruno
Mars takes his time
and it's coming yes area being
investigated this is exactly what we
want right the reason why I'm stood in
this corner is because when he opened
the door it will hide us in the corner
of the room so he doesn't know we are
here and for some reason they don't look
in the mirror on this game even though
Santa Claus he stood right behind him
once he started out the sink will sort
him out don't worry about moving his
body because nobody comes into here and
also this little young lady out here
she's not bothered that Santa Claus is
in this room or in this building so we
don't have to worry about her next just
round this corner there is a camera so
switch to your pistol figure out which
way to go and just shoot the camera like
that do better than that thank you very
much right up we go so on the next floor
there are two guards we need to get rid
of before we can smash the chandelier
down on our victims noggin so we're
gonna peg it round here and jump in this
window and the first is just to the
right so we can strangle him and yes it
is a crowbar all this this explains why
I failed last time there a crowbar that
guy in the head and we're waiting for a
chap to be just down here with his hat
on that we can smash the Guru so in the
meantime let's just do some housekeeping
maybe we'll dump these bodies away while
we're waiting oh just seen it forgot it
was there right you know I said shoot
the camera earlier don't bother
there is no need because in the corner
of the room is this bad boy we can
destroy all evidence it doesn't matter
if you've been spotted by the camera
don't waste time like I did you could
probably get a much higher score let's
see if he's here yet
[Music]
who's here here we go and it should bonk
him on the head oh sorry my dragon and
then we don't simply yet jump out of the
window and just retrace our steps
basically so piggy get back downstairs
the money has been wired to your account
[Music]
[Music]
can we enter the car it's not the right
car okay change of plan we're gonna go
down to the jetty we'll go to the jetty
and we'll get on a boat
[Music]
[Music]
and you're done simple as that so that's
how you do elusive target 16 dressed as
Santa Claus let's see if we get south
assassin ratings
yes elusive target the Guru Silent
Assassin right so we've unlocked the
Italian suit with gloves which looks
very camp but I'm all for camp and
169,000 so if you don't waste time
shooting the camera you should be able
to get a much higher score maybe get up
the leaderboards you're watching
PlayStation granade my name is Adam
please give us a like and maybe even
subscribe and if you new around these
parts have a look at this video there's
one lovely one on the left and there's
an even lovelier one on the right thanks
for your time see you next time